in power for 16 years angela merkel
wasn't afraid of confronting american
presidents
she stepped down as german chancellor in
december
replaced by olive schultz it meant a
fresh start in us german relations
something welcomed by a man who saw joe
biden's election as a good thing
for a while we feared that for the
previous government under president
trump it made no difference whether a
country was a democracy and a friendly
ally or not it is now clear what binds
us together
when it comes to international affairs i
think they very much come from the same
mindset they both
believe in the transatlantic alliance
also on russia basically the position is
very clear and very similar there should
be no change of borders in europe
it's not the first time the two have met
they spoke on the fringes of the g20
summit in rome in october when schultz
was finance minister and virtually after
he became chancellor they'll meet face
to face now with a looming international
crisis
we are all concerned about the situation
on the ukrainian border
with russian troops gathered on the
ukrainian border joe biden has promised
sanctions for any incursion but there's
a worry the russians might retaliate by
cutting off gas supplies to europe and
the hardest hit
will be germany the brunt of the
blowback costs from economic sanctions
whether it's financial sanctions on
banks whether it is energy sanctions
whether it is suspending north stream
two forever will be borne by the
europeans and by some europeans not by
all europeans that also has political
implications
olive schultz is the head of the
centre-left social democratic party as a
career politician who came late to the
top job he's been called the german joe
biden
the two have a lot in common shared
goals mutual objectives but schultz
knows it also plays well at home
when there's a german chancellor ready
to tell a u.s president where to go
alan fisher al jazeera washington